[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] them
[Music]
hump day is here
happy hump day it's wednesday
noon eastern 11 central nine pacific you
know what time that is
every single weekday right here youtube
twitter twitch and now on the fight
facebook of midas touch the mind is
touch facebook page thank you tongue
tied with it
live
every single weekday
the tony michaels podcast we're coming
at you today we have a special person
who's coming on you guys know kfa karen
agnipolo of legal af podcast from midas
touch legal af on the wednesday edition
they're going to drop an addition she's
probably going to talk about that we're
also going to talk about um some
developments
in the january 6 case
uh whether it's the the feds or the
january 6 select committee i've got a
little bit of footage and a couple
stories
i want to show you and we're going to
get
kfa's
legal perspective on it and what she
thinks about it we're also going to ask
her about this
frank james
suspect in the sunset park subway
shooting
we seen yesterday morning the
suspect came on to a subway car set off
some smoke devices and then started
firing into the crowd
and apparently has left
some breadcrumbs now rather it is
actually frank james it seems like
that the law enforcement would not be
naming his name if they really didn't
think he was the suspect but apparently
he's left behind some credit cards and
some weapons and some other evidence
that it's possibly him and this guy has
a youtube channel so we're going to ask
we're going to ask karen
what she thinks about this
she was in the she was formerly in the
manhattan da's office so she would
have dealt with cases similar to this
if it were under their jurisdiction so i
think i think we really need to ask her
about this case and
what is going to happen with it so kfa
will be joining us
15 minutes after the hour so we'll see
her in just a few minutes we'll get kfa
on here
some other some other news
some other news
remember we do bonehead of the week
we do bonehead of the week every single
week on friday in the second hour we put
up a poll
on at tony michael's pod the twitter
page for the podcast at tony michael's
pod you can go vote every single week
for the bonehead of the week we've been
putting it up on thursdays because we
really hold off now because there's so
many [ __ ] boneheads but the news that
i just read
we had a former bonehead on here
who was a trump supporter who committed
election fraud
voter fraud ah wouldn't you know voter
fraud it wasn't those goddamn dominion
machines it was the trump supporters in
the villages down in florida
apparently
that the two men who were
charged
with voter fraud down at the villages in
florida have been sentenced to
i don't know they they're gonna pick up
trash and wash police cars or some [ __ ]
and you know say they're sorry or
something and this is really stupid that
they don't punish these people
they should punish the [ __ ] out of these
white dudes who committed voter fraud
all this noise all this talk all this
nonsense about voter fraud and democrats
and stealing elections and the big lie
and we see
actual voter fraud
we see it it's right there they plead
guilty to it it's it's clear as day that
they were trying to
steal the election for trump by
by fraudulently voting more than once
all the talk all the noise all the
[ __ ] that we have to go through
every single [ __ ] day
at the department of justice is is
trying to work its way through thousands
and thousands of indictments probably
for january 6
because of the big line because of the
[ __ ] of the voter fraud and mail-in
ballots and dominions and
bamboo ballots and watermark just on and
on and on the [ __ ] goes
and here we have clear-cut cases of the
the few cases of voter fraud that you'll
find and it's republicans [ __ ]
pedocon kid diddling republicans that
are
committing voter fraud
and they make them do a couple hours of
community service
and take some [ __ ] weird-ass class
for civics
as if these people don't know how to
vote or some [ __ ] they know how to vote
they committed voter fraud
it's the [ __ ] point people who don't
know how to vote don't know how to
commit voter fraud
[ __ ] idiots
that's what we got though that's where
we're at
so that's what brought bonehead of the
week up in my mind because um i i forget
the guy's name already i already forget
this guy's name i don't know i can't i
can't let me let me see if i can find
his name here real quick
uh charles barnes i think is the the
bonehead that we had
on bonehead of the week a while back
when he was charged and arrested for
voter fraud
in the name of trump
it's really [ __ ] stupid
that they get community service really
community service and they gotta they
gotta take a they gotta take a class oh
well
all the while there's a black woman in
texas
who serves a prison sentence
for unknowingly
mark unknowingly using a ballot that she
shouldn't have used
hmm
seems seems kinda
something something about it seems
different huh i wonder what it is
i wonder what it could be
get the [ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ]
so we're gonna go through that story
today hopefully we uh
we can go through that with gabe sanchez
our co-host and executive producer
he'll be he'll be joining us after kfa
and we can go through that previous
bonehead in that story i also
i also want to ask gabe about this ben
shapiro video have you guys seen this
holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
ben shapiro speaking at some kind of i
don't know where he's at i don't know
where ben shapiro is at where he's
speaking at but he's speaking at some
kind of event and he's taking questions
from the audience
and you gotta we're gonna show the video
i don't want to give it away because
it's not a long video but i'm sure it'll
be a long discussion about the video
but ben shapiro um you guys know ben
shapiro he doesn't know how to please
his wife he doesn't you know he just he
doesn't know these things
you know this alpha male ben shapiro has
no idea about sex and you know he's been
pretty public about it on his show
he he makes a big deal about these
things that really
in all actuality should probably be
private and not that big of a deal but
he makes big deals about him on the show
he talks about his wife's private parts
they're obsessed with genitalia abs
these pedicons these republicans these
these conservatives are completely
obsessed
with genitalia and he even talks about
it on his show
so we'll we'll break down the video and
show you how this guy just burns ben
shapiro's house to the ground
at this event
um and like i said the video is like i
don't know seven or eight seconds long
but i'm sure the discussion could be
about eight hours on the subject
of ben shapiro
um
the other thing i i want to um go
through today we have a couple videos
there's a good liar video out of a q a
honor
um holy moly at a trump rally whoosh
i'm saying some really just wacky ass
[ __ ] so i hope to go through that with
gabe as well and then and then we have
we have bill maher on joe rogan's
podcast
talking about how the covet vaccine is a
cure
what in the actual [ __ ]
this is this this is more of the
nonsense
that we have to deal with
and and really honestly
the whole the whole clip
these two are huffing on two big fat
cigars i'm like really
really we're gonna take health advice
from two guys who are sitting here
drinking alcohol and
puffing on two big fat cigars really
that's who you're gonna come on i mean
i'm not saying i wouldn't sit around and
have a few drinks and drink and smoke
cigars but i'm not running around acting
like i know more than what doctors in
the cdc know
i'm not
do not listen to me with medical advice
it's probably not a good idea
it's probably it's probably not probably
not you should listen to the experts now
the other video i want a couple other
videos i want to show you today is you
you see mike pence the former vice
president
mike pence
said something about how he stood up the
putin or he punched him in the face or
he will smith him i don't know some [ __ ]
how he how he's so tough on putin well
uh jojo from jurors you know we the
friend of the show
she she went back and checked the video
and uh
mike pence you might want to ease up on
the whole you will smith
vladimir putin [ __ ] you might want to
ease up on that narrative because
it really does seem like
um
you couldn't get a word in edgewise
really
so this idea that somehow
he didn't like what you had to say it's
kind of it's [ __ ] and and also in
the video we see john bolton
and he's almost holding like a he he
should have been wearing like a vladimir
putin i love vladimir putin's shirt like
he just he was oh he was a huge fan
loved him loved him he was so into it
so we'll watch that video as well the
other video i want to show you
is a very important video when it comes
to the freedom of the press now ron
desantis
that [ __ ] nazi scumbag down in
florida
trying to turn florida into a fascist
state that's what he wants for the
nation that's what he wants for our
federal government and that's what
they'll do if they win this year in the
midterms
is kick out journalists because they ask
questions
pull them use the police
to pull them and security forces to pull
them out of a press conference for
asking questions and then they pull a
journalist out for videotaping the whole
scenario
so we're going to watch that video i
think it's important for everyone to see
you know here at the tony michaels
podcast we do not look away we don't
which leads me to one of the last videos
i want you to see today and we're gonna
we're gonna show this video
with kfa karen agnipolo here in just a
few minutes when we bring her on
um it is of this
suspect in the sunset park subway
shooting uh frank james um he had a
video online
uh apparently had a youtube video a lot
of them are kind of disturbing
this one uh plays into the hands of the
insurrectionist plays into the hands of
the pedocons the kid diddler republicans
of the race war that they want
and the best weapon to defeat fascism is
democracy not violence
violence never proves your point
in a democracy
it never gives you a leg up so that you
can
be more democratic from a day-to-day
basis
and to strive for liberty equity
and equality for all
we do not need to live in a segregated
state a segregated nation
that notion is absolutely ridiculous
we're all human beings we have to bring
humanity back
to our public discourse
and the way we do that is democracy and
you must participate in it you have to
you have to participate and that's the
only that's the only way that's the only
way and that's what we do here every
single weekdays try to participate in
the democracy show you these things
bring you the the heartbreaking news
and a [ __ ] kind of style right here
on the tony michaels podcast every
single weekday noon eastern 11 central
nine pacific on youtube twitter twitch
go follow us
on youtube and subscribe to the youtube
channel just search the tony michaels
podcast you will find it there or you
can watch us on the facebook page of
midas touch because minus touch is our
is our partner and speaking speaking of
midas touch we have we have a great
a great midas touch
legal af
personality with us today you guys know
that we've uh we've had her on before
and and i think she's uh dropping an
episode today so we'll have to ask her
today about uh the wednesday episode
that's dropping today but you know her
as kfa karen f
egg nipple oh she she really
complimented me last time that i got her
name right i hope i'm still getting
right karen am i still am i still
getting it right
yes you are oh great great good to have
you back good to have you back how are
you i'm great i'm great thanks for
having me yeah yeah well we love to have
you on the show because we really want
um some of the hard-hitting legal
analysis for some of these cases i have
a lot of things i wanted to uh to show
you today um do you want to start with
the frank james thing or would you
rather start with the january six what
what is your preference here
i kind of want to start with the frank
james just because it's super sad what's
happening in new york right now and
what's going on so we might as well talk
about it so tell us tell us your
perspective tell us what you're seeing
there um because you are in new york um
and then i i have a video that i want a
show of him
um actually giving a sort of diatribe
and then um we can go through that
because there's a lot of new evidence
this morning that has surfaced um he's
left behind some breadcrumbs and that's
how it seems like law enforcement has
figured out who
who frank james is and why they suspect
him to be the shooter
yeah so
look new york is never going to quite uh
get past 9 11. you know a lot of people
here still have ptsd and trauma from
the events of 9 11 and and sort of how
shocking it is and how shocking that was
and
that when things like this happen it
kind of just harkens back to those times
and it was very hard you know it was a
very hard day yesterday for a lot of
people there were a lot of people who
said it brought back a lot of feelings a
lot of memories you know manhattan and
new york city and brooklyn you know
they're very dense places and people all
cooperate with one another in the social
contract of getting along and you know
riding the subway together and taking
care of each other and it works and it's
a very safe place to be except when
something like this happens you realize
how vulnerable you can be and that's
what a lot of people felt you know it
was rush hour there were a lot of people
on the subway
uh kids going to school
you know and high school kids travel by
themselves on the subway uh here and
you've just got a lot of people who had
a lot of um a lot of memories come back
whether they were on in the subway or
not when it happened and then you hear
the stories of the people who are in the
subway you know it's all of a sudden
you've got somebody um
you know detonating
these devices that cause gas to you know
fill the subway and disorient people
and then you've got a shooter who just
fired off round after round after round
i think
he ended up hitting about 10 people
there's still some people who are in
critical condition others got injured
from either panic attacks or being
trampled and it was just a terrifying
terrifying situation and
the one of the great things about new
york city is i can confidently tell you
that i am 100
sure that the nypd will catch this
individual
and that's one of the reasons i love
living here is is the nypd there's
nothing like them in the world and they
will solve this crime part of me wonders
if they'll if he'll if they'll catch him
alive or if he's going to commit suicide
um just from the pressure
the manhunt the manhunt pressure that
will happen to him
uh so who knows i'm surprised he got
away you know he's a little bit older
he's not in the greatest shape he's not
like a young guy he's in his 60s and
when something like this happens with so
many people around i was surprised that
he that he got away frankly but i so
we'll see i'm not worried that they're
going to catch him soon
hopefully there will be no other
uh people who are hurt in the process or
beforehand
um yesterday they said he was a person
of interest and you know they get that
fairly quickly from as you call them the
bread club crumbs the clues you know
another great part of new york city is
um
you is everything it's so densely
populated that there's video cameras
everywhere and to get into the subway
you have to leave a digital footprint by
using either your metro card or some
kind of a device and you know every and
and he left a key behind to a u-haul and
they were able to track that down to who
rented the u-haul i mean you know that
he left a bunch of clues and it was
pretty clear uh that he was somebody
they wanted to talk to and so that
yesterday they announced he was quote a
person of interest and that what that
means is he is somebody they want to
talk to they think he has evidence but
they don't know for sure
yet or they don't have probable cause to
believe yet that he is 100 the person
who committed the crime and this morning
at about 10 o'clock in the morning uh
if you're in new york city your phone
did one of those sort of um
like an alert
like an alert yeah these loud alerts
that that you don't get them very often
you know sometimes they're wet sometimes
yeah it's amber alert or something yes
exactly so it was one of those sort of
loud uh alerts and it was about him and
saying he's wanted and he's no longer a
person of interest he is now the suspect
right so they had a breakthrough in the
case i don't know what it is but then
some kind of breakthrough that now they
have probable cause to arrest him
there's a 50 000 reward to catch him uh
apparently one of the the cameras in the
subway station was not working um
unfortunately so they're they're asking
anyone who had cell phone video uh from
the incident to um to
come forward and bring that forward
because there's other clues they will
see
in that video and hopefully you know
this this person um this this frank
james has neighbors and friends and a
circle a social circle who will also
close in on him and turn him in and you
know it's funny he he's like i said he's
sort of this unknown guy no one ever
heard of him before but now you you look
backward and there are tons of clues and
tons of of you know red flags which
you're going to show us with the video
in a minute but you know he was posting
all the stuff about the world trade
center
and you know
it's going to happen again and these
people the same people they're not going
to forget about us and want to kill us
and then he had a a picture or an avatar
he called it of a of a
nuclear like what looked like a nuclear
explosion over a big city saying you
know what do you think that that these
countries that that have something like
this aren't going to use it it's only a
matter of time you know so that kind of
stuff he's very bigoted he hates the
mayor you know we have this great new
mayor
eric adams you know he's
african-american and frank james is
african-american but he's going you know
he's going after him trying to create
racial issues with him um
and you know he's he's just really kind
of taught he talks about slavery you
know he was just kind of going after
everybody in in one of these rants that
you know if anyone had seen it before
they'd say oh this is someone we should
definitely
uh take a look at because he's either a
domestic terrorist or he's severely
mentally ill it doesn't really matter
which one because he's clearly on the
verge of of about to do something and
and somehow he was able to do it it'll
just be interesting to as the days and
weeks go by to learn more and more about
him and as i said i am 100 confident
they'll catch him uh dead or alive asap
because that's the nypd they truly are
you know i've worked with with the nypd
for um for three decades and
it's just uh
that they're true truly the best there
is in the world and um and i feel safe
knowing that they're here
and they're here to protect us and uh
they'll catch them so this this frank
james character he had a youtube channel
and people have been scouring through it
and it looks like the some of the
pictures that the nypd put out were
actually screenshots from some of the
videos that he was putting up on some of
his social media um and he was he was uh
basically saying what he was you know
going to do not in so many words but um
he was in his content it was um
he was making really pointed threats and
this video that i found and i'm not sure
who originally posted but i think
michael rappaport actually is where i
found it um that posted this video and
it's a rant where he's talking about um
things that are happening in our country
right but he has this very very violent
perspective of it um and let's show this
video because i think it's very
important to know
what he's thinking and then why
why what he's thinking about the
situations that are happening in this
country is completely 100 percent uh
180. and i tell the american [ __ ] this
i keep telling you the same thing
white people and black people as we call
ourselves should not have any contact
with each other you still refuse to
understand this
you want to make them some [ __ ] story
about some jesus and the bible said dumb
[ __ ] they don't see it that way
they hate your [ __ ] guts
i think you're karen that he's he's
talking um he's saying they hate your
[ __ ] guts and i think he's saying uh
white people
um and that in in his case to be made
here is to have a segregated country um
which is
for all for all purposes um absolutely
what
the insurrectionist some of the racists
and bigots in the republican party seem
to want um when they're passing some of
these laws they're trying to
diminish black people's vote they're
trying to ostracize the others quote
unquote from society whether it be black
people whether it be lgbtq community um
and but he does have a skewed view
just listen in here
and why they hate your guts
because they know that your rightful
places as a [ __ ] slave
in this country they know that
you're the only one who doesn't realize
that
and now you want to be equal to them by
force
they didn't choose to elect they didn't
elect to make you you had to force them
to make you an equal
and now
they're just getting more angry and more
angry their anger is building building
up and nothing can happen here
differently than what happened over
in europe with the jews
i want you to believe that that's
possible i want you to delude yourself
and tell yourself this [ __ ] punk ass
[ __ ] about that could never happen
here
that could never happen here those are
famous [ __ ]
last words
that could never happen here
yes the [ __ ] could and it will
um so he's he's uh he's obviously in a
state of mind where
um he almost it sounds like uh race war
is what he wants and i kind of posted
this that this is what the
the republicans the neocons the pedicons
the
um really the white supremacists in this
country that's what they want the
insurrectionist that's what they wanted
um you know which probably leads us into
the january 6 insurrection here in our
conversation on that but
even even during the january assistance
erection we've seen that the oath
keepers had a qrf across
the potomac
it seems like part of the plan was for
stewart rhodes and the oath keepers and
possibly the proud boys and other groups
um to stoke violence with black lives
matter and other groups who weren't
there who didn't show up to the
insurrection uh thank goodness i guess
um but to try to cause chaos and and
have this race war kind of uh narrative
that they want i mean that's why tucker
carlson and fox news continue to to beat
this drum about black lives matter in
antifa
about the january 6 insurrection they
keep beating that drum but it sounds
like he's bought some of that some of
that bs right he's bought some of that
bs and he's using it for his cause um
which is to commit violence and and
and what his cause he thinks his cause
causes
how do you see it
look it's it's so sad you know it's it's
it just makes me so sad i want to learn
much more about him before i i sort of
say anything you know i want to and you
don't just wake up at 62 years old and
suddenly shoot up a subway station you
know this man has lived a whole life
and i want to know more about him and
what his experiences are
but i i i don't know why he did that you
know of all things it's what you know
why is he doing sort of what he just did
and creating terror and
and etc especially here in new york city
where you don't really have that kind of
racism the way you have um i think in
other areas where they are
looking where where all of these sort of
dog whistles of racism have um
right have really you know sort of a
welcome a welcome year you know new york
city is is very progressive and um it's
a place that doesn't tolerate racism or
hate crimes or anything like that and
yet he goes after this mayor
and he creates this sort of havoc in our
subway so so it'll be interesting to see
kind of where this goes and what it does
but it's just
what's happening in this country is so
sad and i think it only um if where in
the in the past if you had people who
had views like him it was definitely
marginalized and in the shadows and now
these types of views are um
are
are espoused and celebrated openly at
rallies and people are elected you know
saying things like this and and we don't
as a society you know
when you look at whether it's whether
it's race or abortion or voting rights
or trans rights or any other any other
issue the country divides in half
um you've got at least 26 or 27 states
who that are that are passing laws uh to
to kind of do that
um you know whatever whatever that is
but you know that sort of that kind of
marginalization of individuals uh based
on hate and racism right it's almost
well it's almost like they can't come up
with a piece of legislation that doesn't
have this this hint of discrimination in
it no matter if they're taking away
women's liberty rather taking away um
you know lgbt communities liberty
children's liberty uh trans people what
whatever it is they're they're really
they can't even come up with a piece of
legislation without discriminating
against someone it seems whether it's
voting rights or or your skin color or
your gender i mean they're just
completely obsessed with taking away
people's liberty and i mean exactly
right it's not surprising
it's not surprising and so so what's
happening in this country is
is stoking the fears and concerns and
and again sort of these crazy thoughts
that people like frank james have and it
i don't know if it emboldens them
or if it's somehow um kind of brings
them
out from the shadows and into the
forefront but again why target new york
city why why do something like this
those are the things that make no sense
to me but i guess i don't really
understand
you know what's in the mind of
a terrorist so well and that's really
what he is you know he he sought to
create fear and terror right and he said
it on this youtube channel because there
were several clips that i've seen this
morning where he was absolutely um um
stoking the the fear and the terror
speaking of of terror not to to do a t
too hard of a transition but um i i seen
a video over the weekend um speaking of
domestic terrorism and insurrectionist
of uh liz cheney on
jake tapper's show um we had uh let me
see if i can pull that video up but
basically uh over the weekend liz cheney
has come out and said now i'm not sure
you know exactly what her intention is
here i think she definitely knows um you
know she's not going to go on any kind
of
national tv show without knowing exactly
what she's saying and exactly why she's
saying it um but in this clip she is
um she's very pointed about what she
believes that the president did or
didn't do and more importantly uh rather
rather
it's criminal and they can give a
referral
now the opinion whether they're going to
or not i guess is a questionable but
let's watch this clip here and then
we'll talk about it on the other side
here
you're the vice chair of the january 6
committee the new york times reporting
this morning that your committee has
concluded that you have enough evidence
to make a criminal referral for
president trump to the justice
department for obstructing an official
proceeding and for conspiracy to defraud
the united states um is that true do you
have enough evidence to refer trump for
criminal charges
well we have not made a decision about
referrals on the committee i think that
it is absolutely the case it's
absolutely clear that um what president
trump was doing what what a number of
people around him were doing that they
knew it was unlawful they did it anyway
i think you certainly saw that in the
decision that was issued by judge carter
a few weeks ago
where he concluded that
it was more likely than not that the
president of the united states was
engaged
in criminal activity
i think what we have seen is a massive
and well organized and well-planned
effort that used multiple tools to try
to overturn an election
you've seen just in the last few days
a plea agreement from one of the leaders
of the proud boys which which lays out
in really
chilling detail the extent to which
violence was planned um the extent to
which uh the message that went out on
december 19th about the planning about
the rally in washington
and don't forget donald trump tweeted
out that message be be there be wild
that the day after that message uh the
organization and the planning started
and and that they understood that they
knew that they were going to attempt to
use violence to try to stop the transfer
of power that is the the definition of
an insurrection
uh so so we have liz janey here um
kind of drawing lines right like between
evidence i think i think that's what
she's doing she's not actually doing
anything but telling the american people
hey look at this over here and look at
this these two things are the same and
one a couple of things here number one
the the
uh on the eastman emails that they were
trying to hide behind attorney uh client
privilege uh judge carter out of
california the federal judge said no
now that you committed crime it's not
attorney client privilege if you're
committing crime um and he basically
laid out a case for obstruction of
official procedure am i writing that and
saying that
yeah so so the case in california was a
very limited case in scope and it was
literally
do i have to turn over emails or not it
wasn't like jack niecemann that's john
eastman does he have to turn over emails
it wasn't even john eastman believe it
or not it was chapman university where
he was employed because it was their
email that he was using that okay
correct so he refused to turn over his
email
and so the prosecutor said you know in
in every
you know there's
there's a server you know and every time
you send an email and it comes from a
place and those emails live on the
server of chapman university so if he
won't turn it over lex asked the
university and the university uh went to
court and basically the very narrow
question before judge carter was
are these email do these emails um
are they privileged essentially and um
if and and if not then they get turned
over if so they they um
they don't
and so the bottom line is the way it
works is it's not sort of a blanket
assertion of are all the emails uh
attorney client the judge has to go
email by email communication by
communication and apply the standards of
whether it's attorney client and so what
you're saying is the judge gets to put
their eyes on those emails they get to
read line for line so they're getting
not just the context of the email but
they are actually receiving the actual
email with the time date and stamp the
subject line that who it went to where
it went to
and the actual subject the signature the
entire nine yards on those emails is
that is that fair to say when they get
to make that decision
exactly and i think there was a hundred
plus emails in question that that that
they were sort of quibbling over
and that's those are the emails uh it's
give or take i don't remember the exact
number at this point but the so the
judge went through them
and made a determination email by email
by email and what was interesting was so
the the judge found that that most of
them were
privileged under the attorney client
privilege meaning uh they were made to
an attorney and and they were made in
the context of representation etc but
there are exceptions to the attorney
client privilege and one of them is
called the crime fraud exception which
means you can't use the attorney-client
privilege as both a sword and a shield
in other words you can't hide behind it
as well you know
as as sort of a um it's my attorney so
you know
so you can't get my my communications if
the communications are planning a crime
together
and you know you're conspiring to make
to commit a crime together those are no
longer privileged communications
so the judge in order to find
that these uh emails
fell into a crime fraud exception had to
find that there was a crime and so he
that's how he backdoored his way into a
44-page
road map for the department of justice
on the crimes that donald trump
committed and it's crime after crime i
think there was three separate crimes
that that the judge said he it is more
likely than not that he committed and
that to me was just a stunning road map
to the department of justice to say
these are the crimes this is the
evidence and you can bring this case and
you know it's interesting because you
know people talk about kind of whether
or not congress should make a criminal
referral
to the department of justice and that
just makes me scratch my head it's not
really you know they don't that's not
didn't this didn't this judge kind of
make a criminal referral in this nobody
has to make by the way there's no such
thing as you don't need to make a
criminal referral you know right if a
prosecutor sees this decision out in
california and says hey this k this
judge is making a really good case
here's what they're saying and we have
the evidence to back it up
they don't need a referral right you
know do you know they absolutely do not
need a referral there are very limited
times when you need a referral but just
to give you an idea of how
a pro how prosecutors get cases
i know pr i have seen a prosecutor i've
seen an inc like a new york times story
where they do investigative reporting
and they lay out
what looks like a crime that is enough
that can be enough to issue subpoenas
and look into and doing your own
investigation
you're a former prosecutor you know but
you don't need a referral you know a
police can make an arrest and bring you
a case or a victim can come forward and
say this is what happened or you know
you you just it's not a thing unless
there's a couple of times when it is a
thing so for example um
for example the january 6 committee uh
asked that
so the january 6
committee in the house has already heard
from hundreds of witnesses and people
have come and testified including ivanka
trump who was apparently quite helpful
according to representative cheney
that's what she said you know but but
she didn't she didn't take the fifth she
didn't sort of say i'm not gonna answer
this question i'm not gonna answer that
question apparently she gave substantive
testimony so so people are going there
and testifying but there but two
individuals gavino and navarro and i
always forget sort of which one was the
advisor
dan scavino is the social media dan
navarro is is the wackadoo he's the
really wacky tv
steve bannon trader tv person now yeah
exactly okay thank you um so basically
they are refusing to go before the
committee and
that is what you that is this kind of
scenario where you would sit you would
make a criminal referral because in that
scenario congress is the victim and yeah
because it's a crime against congress
right it's a crime against it's not a
crime against like i mean the
insurrection is a crime against congress
but it's a it's a it's a doj issue not
not exactly
um the crime isn't committed inside of a
subpoena that is given by exactly
exactly so i'm actually hoping that the
january 6 committee does not make a
criminal referral because a it's it's
only symbolic there's no reason to do it
other than
to be symbolic and the reason i'm hoping
they don't do it is because the minute
you do do that you're infusing and
infecting a criminal investigation with
politics and because the january 6
committee is always going to be viewed
as political for what no matter which
party you're affiliated with it's going
to be viewed as political um
partly because it's not only are they
politicians who are doing the
investigation as opposed to law
enforcement and prosecutors but also
don't forget the people the very people
who are doing this investigation are the
victims of the crime how can they be
objective you know like it would be it's
it would be like they were the ones
running and hiding from the violence yes
exactly it would literally be like
having a rape victim uh who is accusing
someone of sexual assault to also be on
the jury right you know in this country
we we care about things like fairness
and propriety and
we should we should we should and that's
the idea right i do
sometimes sometimes it seems that way
and even if the january 6 committee is
is a perfect committee and they do a
great job and it's not political and
it's just to take the facts where they
lead
to me by by giving a ref an unnecessary
referral it just infuses politics into
something that doesn't need to be there
and the minute you do that you sort of
taint the criminal justice process and
and it's time to you know donald trump
what he has done to the department of
justice the fbi the cia you know all
these institutions that used to give us
comfort that we felt were protecting us
that we thought were kind of above
politics and and above reproach he's
really sort of called so many things
into into question you know even james
comey with the hillary clinton you know
situation all of that it's just i want
to go back to the days where we trust
our um our law enforcement and our
justice system because it really is
something that that we have to be it's
it's the rule of law it's what it's the
foundation of the bedrock that keeps
everything together and so i my thought
is keep congress out of this and let
meric garland do his job and i can
assure you they are investigating this
case they have already called for
another hundred plus prosecutors to uh
investigate and prosecute the january
sixth insurrection they are building a
case and they are taking following the
evidence where it leads and if the
evidence the breadcrumbs as you called
them earlier with with um frank james if
the if the breadcrumbs lead to donald
trump he will bring that case we just
have to take a deep breath and let the
justice system do their job it takes
time it always does and
i i just like i said i just hope they
don't infuse it and infect it with
politics because that's the death knell
to um to a criminal prosecution but
don't you think that's what liz cheney's
doing here she's like standing standing
there waving her hands like hey we got
this right like she's she's yelling and
screaming because she can't just like
walk up to merrick garland be like hey
here here here's the evidence in a
satchel right like that's not exactly
how it works because they are two
separate investigations the one house
truly is a political investigation
because it's a political body whereas
the doj if they are bringing grand
juries which it seems like there are
several grand juries that are being
convened um not just in this case but in
other cases that are surrounding trump
and the trump administration but we
really we really see liz cheney trying
to draw lines here and what i mean by
that
is when she says about the eastman memos
or the emails excuse me um about the
eastman minimal the plan to i call it
the cheeto dust kangaroo coup um but the
plot to overthrow our constitution um
but we see her drawing a line to that
to this this plea deal with the proud
boys because there is one person there
is one person out there
that is kind of tied into the proud boys
the oath keepers
and donald trump himself and that that
character and he is a character it's uh
it's he's almost like
i don't know if he does this on purpose
but he's like a batman villain almost uh
roger stone um is in the middle of all
of that and what i mean by that is he
was supposed to be protected by the
proud boys the day of january
um for whatever reason his security
detail was switched to one of stuart
rhodes the founder of the oath keepers
lieutenants who has now now pled guilty
so the guy standing right next to roger
stone the entire day of january 6 has
pled guilty to conspiracy of sedition
now this proud boy who was not next to
him that day but we see enrique tario
and stuart rhodes meeting the night or
the day before in a parking garage in dc
discussing the next day and now we see a
proud boy who is enrique tario's
lieutenant
plead guilty to the specific charge that
really interests me
is the conspiracy to obstruct an
official proceeding because that charge
is the same charge we see
that uh judge carter in california said
hey these emails show that there is a
conspiracy to obstruct an official
proceeding
and it just seems so convenient to me
that all these pieces are put together
and liz cheney here is on national tv on
a sunday on cnn going hey hello you know
here's here's your here's your lines
that you're drawing american people
here's what if you want to know the
story here's the story i think that's
kind of what she's saying um
i'm not exactly a liz cheney fan and
what i mean by that is i really am
diametrically opposed to her politics
and i probably always will be uh someone
who votes against voting rights in the
house um i don't feel as a friend to
democracy but i do appreciate that she's
willing
rather that's just to get rid of
trumpism and take her party back i do
appreciate um her ferber to
continue to plunge into this anti-trump
thing um
but i believe that liz cheney is
signaling to the american people through
the media that hey
it's okay
don't get too worried because we see
people out there really trying to stoke
fear on on quote the side of democracy
which i actually do not think that they
are being pro-democracy when they do
this when they question merrick garland
when they question the department of
justice they're going oh they're never
going they're never going to convict
anyone and here uh here we have an oath
keeper a proud boy
both of them
uh plead guilty to conspiracy to
sedition and the other proud boy um plea
guilty to a charge of a conspiracy to
obstruct an official proceeding and then
we see the the email decision that judge
carter brought down and these people are
supposed to have
quote-unquote legal minds and i i guess
i don't have to say their names i could
and i really don't care if i do or not
um but there are some people out there
that i think are being very
anti-democracy and very authoritarian
wanting merrick garland number one mayor
garland is not the one who makes the
decision to prosecute anyone in the
district of columbia i mean he is the
attorney general he's the boss of the
person who gets to decide that but
merrick garland doesn't have a magic
wand like they didn't want bill barr i
mean they were like oh bill barr he's a
fascist and he's going to take over our
government in the justice department and
he's banging up democracy yet here they
are yelling and screaming for merrick
garland did the same thing it doesn't
make any sense and i really have
confidence and i think this road map
isn't a road map for the department of
justice i already think they know all
this [ __ ] they already got this they
know this stuff they're just making sure
when they bring this case that donald
trump and his team doesn't do something
like a speedy trial or try to make sure
that they use the justice system in
their favor i think the justice
department wants to have every i dotted
t crossed to make sure when the trump
chaos machine
starts because that's what's going to
happen if there's indictments brought
not just to him but people who are very
close to him i.e john eastman rudy
giuliani which we heard there's probably
indictments possible indictments coming
out of sdny um
which means there's probably cooperation
there with not just the ukraine mess but
also january 6 but also uh john eastman
roger stone steve bannon and some of
these others when these if these
indictments start to fall um that trump
chaos machine will kick in and i believe
that's another thing that the department
of justice is doing is to make sure that
they can combat that trump chaos machine
that will ensue so i hope that we have
confidence i know that you do um i guess
my question would be do you think i'm
right in the connections that liz cheney
is trying to draw am i just conspiracy
theory in this or am i really seeing
something that hey these people are
surrounded and these charges look the
same and they're pleading guilty to this
and the department of justice is
building a case um i call it little fish
big fish stuff right so it seems like
they're working their way up the ladder
rung by rung by rung and they're getting
to that abstract because i believe
that's what donald trump if he's charged
for january 6 that's the charge is
obstruct conspiracy commit to commit
obstruction of official proceeding um i
believe that's probably the charge am i
right or am i just crazy here
well um
you're not crazy
i will compliment your ability to string
um lots of facts and things that look
like they belong together together you
know and that's that's it's good it's
it's impressive actually um when i look
at look when i've seen liz cheney she
has hitched her she's still a politician
at the end of the day right and she has
hitched her political wagon on being
anti-trump and so she her very survival
has to it depends on on being right and
bringing him down and making sure that
this prosecution happens and happens
asap and so i think she's putting
pressure
on but you know with the american people
through the media she's putting pressure
on on the department of justice to to do
this and that's exactly the thing that i
i think is is bad you can't do that you
have to back off and let them do their
job and not be a part of that um but no
i i do think what you're saying is right
i i think that
what happens is you you know they start
to investigate things on the outside and
then they close in you know they they
investigate the people that they can
uh you know the people who are in the
capital and who went and and did you
know the things that they're doing and
hopefully some of them will cooperate
and give the organizers and then the
organizers will give you know then
they'll subpoena emails and and
communications and phone records and
then you've got this seven hour this
coin this total coincidental seven hour
gap
of no phone calls uh and phone records
of donald trump during the insurrection
so they're going to try to get people to
testify and cooperate about that you
know and they're just going to get
closer and closer and closer and see
what they can do to build this case
uh you know so i look
what you see is happening is absolutely
happening and um and i think you're
probably right uh when it comes to liz
cheney here
well i i appreciate the compliment and
everyone in the um in the thing is
they they love you karen they love you
kfa every everyone in the chat love you
they do they love you um even mj says
here uh kfa twice in one day is amazing
i can't i i can't chat when she's
speaking so they love you now i will ask
you because we will have to let you go i
do appreciate you joining us but tell us
about the episode because there is going
to be an episode dropping uh today of
the wednesday edition of legal af so
tell us about the episode tell us you
and popock what do you talk about today
on this episode or can you even reveal
it this is the big secret sure i can
reveal it go ahead yeah
we're so today we're talking about
there was just a case that just really
really upset me i mean that's the fun
thing about being having a podcast is
when you see something that upsets you
you can just say that's what i'm going
to talk about and people are going to
listen and and the thing that really
upset us this week and me in particular
was this woman in texas who was a you
know who who took
an abortion pill and
uh afterward had had a reaction to it
and went to the hospital to seek medical
care after um after performing this
self-induced medically induced you know
kind of abortion not not with a a coat
hanger in a back alley not with a
fly-by-night doctor but an actual fda
approved medication but she was having a
reaction she goes to the hospital to
seek
medical attention and the doctors who
are protected by hipaa and privileged
laws
uh called the cops and had her arrested
and they charged her with murder which
is
just stunning to me and the d.a in the
case is is going has is not going to
bring the charges just moving to dismiss
the case but
so you know what's happening in texas is
just just awful and stunning and that's
we spend
some time talking about that we talk
about marjorie taylor green
and you know we we just talk about sort
of some of the things that that really
interest us and you know the things
that that are going on in the world the
same things you're talking about you
know we're all sort of talking about
we're all living through it right we're
all living we're all living through it
but we break it down from a legal
perspective you know rather than just
sort of talk at people and tell them
this is what's happening we try to
explain it so that people can understand
the law and why certain things are
happening and so so that's that's
tonight's episode but a funny thing
happened and when we were taping the
episode um so popock always does the
introduction you know he likes to do the
whole you know welcome to legal af and
you know tonight's episode we're going
to talk about this that and the other
thing and so he set it up that we were
going to talk about you know three
things um
we talked about issue number one we
talked about issue number two and i can
tell he's starting to wrap up
and i'm thinking oh so he didn't get the
three huh he didn't well he so i said so
i was trying to like hint to him you
know okay hey
you know don't forget we got topic
number three and he was like what do you
mean we did that and then i'm starting
to doubt myself did i forget
and then so you know how how that is but
it turns out anyway so we forgot we got
to it we went and did the episode but we
decided you know we're keeping that in
the pod because sure what do we think
because who do we think we are we're
human we're not trying to pretend like
we're you know different than we
actually are more polished than we are
you know i'm not some television person
or you know i don't know you're going to
become that way you're on the tony
michaels podcast you're becoming a
regular this is your second time in two
weeks and next week i hope we can bring
you back on for for more updates so
everyone go go to anywhere that you find
your podcast and just type in
legal af and you will find not just the
wednesday edition but also the saturday
ish where popock and ben myself you know
those guys they do yeah and if you join
us when when the live show happens so
tonight it's uh 8 p.m eastern time week
we all get on and we live chat with
people which is actually the most fun i
love
just like right here everyone everyone's
chatting now amanda said popock is a
silver fox um
and
let's see what else do we have here um
they [ __ ] he's really smart he's yeah he
is smart he is really smart and you know
it shows very professorial yes well
right and then you know they always give
him hell about his backgrounds and his
sweaters or whatever he's wearing you
know so so it's a lot of fun so go check
out legal af on youtube if you want to
check it out live and you want to chat
with kfa and popoc and midas touch um go
go check out the live chat on youtube or
you can find it anywhere you find your
podcast legal af reminder such cameras
for having me it's okay
oh it is and and once a nice break in
the day now i go back to being a lawyer
and doing my legal work billing hours so
yeah okay good good well go make some
money go make some money we don't we
don't we don't want you to to to go
broke over there we want you to keep
coming back on so
enjoy the rest of your day and karen
thank you for coming on uh everyone
again go check out go check out the
wednesday edition tonight 8 p.m eastern
on youtube on minus touch youtube
channel go chat with kfa thank you karen
have a good one bye
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker convoy
there's tammy
by the time we reached dc
we was 50 strong in number
some patriots ran out of gas along the
way
we got plenty of slim jims
skull
near run out natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
circle the city again
years
bomb
dear bob i'm fixing to send you some
more of them doritos you like the red
bag not the lid loving blue one
in your absence i discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and i
even seen my cousin brody in ages
stay strong
wipe your ass at least once a day
ears
tammy
[ __ ] em
[ __ ] em
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
[Music]
what a great breakdown
and not just the uh frank james
search that is going on in new york for
the suspect in the uh sunset
our sun sunset park subway shooting but
also in the january 6th select committee
oh i still haven't seen i'm i'm trying
here i still got her her banner up
what a great great interview
uh great conversation with kfa karen
agnipolo of legal af midas touch legal
af wednesday edition go check it out
again uh tonight you can go to might
just touch uh the the youtube channel
and you can live chat with kfa and pop
and so check it out and then uh if you
want to download it on the uh the
directories you can you can download it
anywhere you find
anywhere you find your podcast so go go
check that out go check that out um i
think we're gonna have gabe sanchez us
joining us here soon
for the shitless roundup where we round
up all the tweety tweets and the trinity
trends of the day
and boy do we have a lot of stuff to
round up again and we have um i have got
some videos i want to show you
uh of
of mike pence
ron desantis bill maher and joe rogan
and we have we
i've got a video i actually want to show
you a better aurora if we get to it uh
about greg abbott and how he's
inspecting trucks at the border now jen
saki dunked greg abbott into the [ __ ]
trash
and there's also a great a fantastic
fantastic ben shapiro video that is just
beautiful mwah i mean it is uh
it's wonderful you guys are gonna love
you guys are gonna love this video uh mj
says what a great interview it is always
a great conversation with kfa if you
guys don't know
if you guys are aware here um kfa was
the number two
in the manhattan da's office so she
knows a thing or two about what she's
talking about
and the other thing too is again she's
super smart
so go check out go check out thank you
mj for the suit for the super chat
go check out legal af
tonight the wednesday edition at 8 p.m
eastern
on midas touch's youtube channel
don't forget to follow us here
on our youtube channel the tony michaels
podcast
follow us here and subscribe and you
will find
i'll try to uh cut out and put the
kfa combo maybe that's what we'll call
it the kfa combo
something like that
we need to come up with a name when
cable because we have the po poc poppin
maybe that's the kfa combo right maybe
that's what we'll do i don't know we'll
come up with something
possibly
uh to to have like a sound or something
so you know
when kfa is on
uh we're being joined by our our co-host
and executive producer let's see if he's
getting his microphone on let's check
and see
you got your microphone on there i do
have my microphone on can you hear me
yeah i can hear you all right wow look
at that how do you like this look do you
like this look or you know you're not
really
maybe maybe you want to go back to you
want to go back to that yeah yeah i
don't know i mean like do people like
the pipe i don't know
i know do people like the big are they
yeah
i don't know i mean decides matter
well the society we live in i don't know
uh here we go here we go
so so um gabe did you did you catch any
of the conversation that we had with kfa
there i did not you did not yeah he's
not well i think he's busy trying to
figure out the microphone yeah yeah i
did catch one part when you guys were
talking about the person of interest in
new york oh okay so yeah you wanna you
wanna comment on that uh the frank james
uh yeah yeah so uh from what i've read
you know well yesterday i mean we we
discussed like certain talking points
that we've made right i think another
one that um
you know i definitely saw coming was the
blm argument right this guy oh yeah
except what i read was it was very much
like black people should be erased
from society in the earth right
why i mean i mean
here's the thing
is that they're going to get extreme
about this right right
white supremacists are going to use this
and they're going to use it as a
bludgeon hammer that's why it's so
disappointing that this person has used
these reasons to
um what seems like commit um or try to
commit a mass murder right a mass
shooting um i mean he did
it was an active shooter um i don't
think anyone has been fatally injured
though correct not that i've read no it
was uh people were taking the hospital
they were injured but there was nothing
they were they were all stable yeah yeah
and one of the and i surmised yesterday
and maybe i'm wrong about this but when
he set off the smoke in the car you
would think that i mean i mean obviously
he had this planned out but i don't
think he really thought past his gas
mask when he thought that the smoke or
not would just impair their vision but
also it would impair his vision um yeah
it's a bit of a i mean like you know
you're
it's almost like he's watching a lot of
like movies right yeah i mean like what
is essentially what happened was that he
kind of like hot boxed the subway car
right right and then decided to shoot in
it now in that you know in in that smoke
people are like you know underneath
seats or holding the guard rail or right
over to the door or whatever so like
yeah he has no clear direction but the
fact that you know you're able to shoot
in a small
contained area and still miss people
dangerous and [ __ ] right yeah it's it's
dangerous but also it's like not well
thought out because you're like well if
i'm trying to cause the most amount of
damage right yeah you wouldn't would i
wouldn't set off
would i distract myself from right well
i don't think you thought that far like
i said i think it was more of a movie if
you watch some of the videos of this guy
and there's all kinds of videos right
now going around twitter the suspect
again he is a suspect right but he's
left a lot of breadcrumbs that makes it
very
almost very obvious that he was he was
the shooter it's almost like he wants
them to know more than anything because
he was i mean there's videos on that he
has on youtube that are basically giving
this away like i seen a video this
morning where he was driving from
wisconsin i guess he lived there and he
drove to pennsylvania and
he's just he just kind of um
it almost seemed like there was this uh
he was giving up on life almost or what
life he had where he was
you know like he was tired of it um
there's a lot of angst a lot of anxiety
it seems like that he was dealing with
so um
but the the the fortunate part about him
setting off the smoke bombs is i
actually think it saved lives oh
definitely i think that's that you know
maybe maybe i'm wrong but in my in my
view of the situation and viewing some
of the video that like you said when you
hot box the right the subway car it
really seems like that that was probably
what helped save those people's lives
his actions
to do a movie like thing where he would
yeah or whatever the hell i don't know
what the hell yeah not sure what the
reason is there but yeah i would imagine
that very much did save lives um
uh from from
you know
for further or worse injury than that
was uh sustained right now you just you
just posted a tweet here um oh did i i
don't know well um maybe i know you you
sent that i retweeted here let's see if
we can bring it up here um it says
narrator he didn't oh this is the mike
pence video
um
so
tell us what you mean by this because i
want to show this video here but tell us
what you mean yeah yeah well you know if
there's any arrested development fans
out there they'll get this reference but
uh mike pence goes oh yeah you know i've
met i've met putin and we've we've gone
[ __ ] slapped him i i right smith yeah
exactly yeah yeah like uh mike pence is
is taking the
ownership of saying that he
was the deterrent for putin ever
invading or attacking the us or ever
trying to do anything right he's like i
met pence or he's like i met putin
multiple times and we went toe to toe
and i told him what i really thought but
then if you look at that video and joe
uh jojo from jersey she found it she
found right she found the video and he
was like okay
okay
and we'll play a little bit of that
because i want people to see because the
part where like
mike pence can't even get a word in
edgewise with like putin
john bolton he's like oh my god
oh it's so good to meet you and i'm like
dude i'm surprised he didn't like open
up his shirt like i love putin oh yeah
or like
he's like
sign my back you're right right right
right can you sign my can you sign my
chest for anything i don't know it's
really weird um when yeah what ball
gives up because you could you normally
can't see his mouth through his mustache
but you can
came through and there was john bolton's
mouth you know well let's watch let's
watch what mike pence's [ __ ] said um
what was this yesterday or the day
before i think it was yes it was
yesterday yeah okay okay let's watch
i've also met vladimir putin he has
churches
he did stand you know i mean next to him
yeah right let me tell all of you yeah
putin only understands strength
oh that's even does he does he really
because the video that we're going to
watch it seems like yeah
he may understand a lot of things but
let's let's continue erica must meet
this moment with american strength
why do they always do this why do you
always do these you know our our
president right now he's like
vladimir putin is a [ __ ] butcher and
he should have genesis power anywhere
and he should commit genocide and here
mike pence is like uh these plat these
stupid murk america america america
that's going to solve our problems
america what i want to know is did mike
pence consult mother before giving the
speech right or like even before meeting
putin he's like okay listen mother
meanwhile in the house his actual mother
pops out and he's like huh and then his
wife pops out and goes which mother you
know right um well you know i what i
wanted to know about this clip is this
actually mike pence i'm not sure that
this is my here's whoa
there is not a fly on his head and
really to me
if we don't have the evidence of the fly
being on his hair i don't know if this
is just like some kind of skin suit that
someone's wearing or something i i mean
there is here's the thing there are many
theories that q have around mike pence
they're like they judge the earlobes oh
okay and the forehead and so i'm not off
i'm not that you're not off here's the
thing it's just like the same q people
who are analyzing they're like oh is
this really uh joe biden right or is
this trump biting face off right right
like well you know it's tough too
to be fair i i said it's mike pence an
er it's a skin suit and really honestly
mike pence is kind of just a
there's really nothing very much like
you know when many uh men in black one
like oh these aliens are kind of
undercover and then he's kind of have
their skin suit that they're right right
right whatever and it turns out there's
just like a little like dude you know
right orion's belt you know that's mike
pence oh except the alien insight is not
intelligent is it the fly is the fly the
one running oh
i don't wait are you talking about where
are you talking about like the cockroach
what did you talk about oh no the flight
the fly that landed on mike oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah i've been controlling this i think
what happened was the fly landed it like
inseminated it's like dna into
right and now that's why
after the election it was like nowhere
to be seen right it was like this all
makes sense and i'm sure there's a
facebook group out there that would
confirm everything that we're seeing and
if there isn't then i'm sure somebody
will make a facebook right but yeah this
is not the real mike pence all right
well let's let's see what mike pence
mike pence would never try to say this
though yeah well you know it it's very
it's again it's very weird the whole
america america america like right again
our president is saying definitive
things about a world leader right and
and and he's like everyone's like oh my
god you can't say that about about putin
like why he is a [ __ ] butcher right
right he does not need to be in power
anywhere like why are also so confused i
want to know what the difference between
just strength to stand up to putin and
say hey this is [ __ ] up and american
strength is like i want to know that i i
would really like to know the difference
here because all i'm seeing is just a
one word toss-on for like buzz words
right doesn't mean anything and if
american strength is what we're about to
see mike pence do then i don't want
american strength right right i don't
want a guy who just goes
okay okay yeah okay hey yeah got it well
let's see because joe joe found this um
right she said earlier tonight mike
pence said i've also met vladimir putin
which he has it'll show him i stood
toe-to-toe with him which he did stand
next to him yeah and i told him things
he didn't want to hear which i don't
know if you know what words like this
this is mike pence this is mike pence
playing the game true two truths and a
lie oh okay mike pence is playing two
truths and a lie right now about putin
because he's true he did he did meet
vladimir putin that's the truth he did
stand toe-to-toe right he was close
relative right that's a day
and then he told him things he didn't
want to hear that's the lie
with mike pence well joe says here well
i went back and looked so here is mike
pence standing toe to toe with putin
looks as if only thing he said is okay
like six times so um we're going to
watch the video here but
the thing about the video because
obviously mike bens cucks in this thing
right totally he might he might be in
the running this week i don't know it
could be but also ben shapiro i don't
know around that well we're going to
watch a bench of your video it's [ __ ]
hilarious um and also there is uh two
truce but no lie in that video but um um
here here we're gonna watch this but the
thing that is the funniest [ __ ] part
about this video other than mike pence
is full of [ __ ] i mean that's not really
that funny it's not really that
surprising at all either that that
obviously there was going to be footage
of him not doing the thing that he said
he did but the best part is when mike
excuse me john i'm going to say mike
michael bolton
michael john
right well i mean
i bet that pisses michael fulton off a
lot yeah yo just like you pissed off
michael bolton from office space you
know right right damn that guy with my
same name right the son of a [ __ ] but
john bolton and his mustache enter in
the chat yeah and it is i feel i really
want like a john madden play-by-play
here because you don't see john bolton
anywhere in the frame right now
before he meets pence oh there he is i'm
just going to mute i'm going to mute it
because it's not really you can't really
hear anything okay there he is he's just
he's just learning christy the thing he
says that is not what he wants to hear
vladimir putin's talking the
interpreters they're talking okay he
said he said okay
uh let's see what else is he gonna say
is he gonna say anything uh
okay
yeah
yeah oh yeah there's the fan boy look at
him look at his look at this look at
this look at that green oh my god
someone said those eyebrows way above
the glasses someone said uh bolton's
boner phone like um pushed pushed mike
pence out of the way here
did you did you know he said boner phone
i think it was on cnn mike jesus christ
oh dude john bolton is that what he was
named
he said trump had motor phones yeah
boner phones not burner boner i mean you
know they're i mean
i mean i guess it depends on how you use
the phrase right right yeah totally
right but apparently um
john bolton used his boner phone here to
uh swipe
right on mike pence and swipe left is
that the correct way to swipe i don't
know swipe right you like swipe left you
do okay so swiping
and then now you can do like a super
like so what i think mike golden here is
he's paying money too not mike baldwin
john bolton we're [ __ ] yeah yeah oh
no okay see i got you saying
okay anyway uh john bolton on his birth
on his boner phone john bolton on the
boner phone he like swiped right but now
you can super like so you can pay more
money so that it gets uh into their uh
pool of people oh to check so what do
you call a super like on a boner phone
um not to be confused with a burner
phone because right right right john
bolton said boner phone on yeah yeah
yeah apparently you know i would it
might be between like cyalis and viagra
a stiff bump or something like that yeah
yeah yeah yeah okay okay
a manufactured bump in a way right right
but i don't think he's super excited
look at he's even covering he's got his
hands i know he's covering he's doing
the old giuliani tuck type thing right i
don't know
like you know there isn't a bed there so
yeah
look at pence just looking around didn't
contribute any of the conversation not
really holding up
well gabe he totally here is saying the
things that vladimir putin does not want
yeah and you know what you know how he
you know he's completely violence you
know how he's saying he's saying with
his eyes right right right that's how
he's doing it maybe it's the fly maybe
it's the fly there was a fly on the
other side that was actually doing the
talking and that's the thing that we're
not seeing
is the mach is the fly running the mike
pence skin suit yeah he's actually doing
the talking and we just don't see it and
mike pence to all fairness kind of looks
like a not not the ventriloquist itself
but the dummy and maybe the yeah the fly
just isn't moving the mouth it's just
the words coming out he's not actually
moving
look i'm not making up a theory right
now but i have this weird impression
that when mike pence goes out he wears
and there's nothing wrong with it but um
i feel like mike pence like if you stop
the frame right here
uh you know he's very much like chest
out right you know
and i don't know if that really how he
is if that's naturally how he is but
what i would say is maybe and again
nothing wrong with this maybe he's
wearing some padding above to make it
seem like his chest is larger so there's
like a monkey like bravo like oh you
know so you think he's wearing
a little weird vest yeah i think so kind
of like a ben shapiro mckees-mo vest
exactly okay yeah yeah yeah okay i
betcha so that's what i'm saying you
know again nothing wrong with it it just
seems like it the posture and the way it
is doesn't seem natural to me right and
it really this video with the the john
bolton um where he's right here where
he's just so good he's just waiting he's
like
he looks right he he saw me he's solid
and he he shook my hand like this is
this reminds me it's it's almost like
john bolton just met his favorite
backstreet boy yeah like pretty much
like and then meanwhile putin's like
bye-bye oh no that's in sync yeah come
on come on i'm sorry you and your you
and your pop culture references
you know um you know it happens it
happens um so the other there's some
more video i want to show you yeah which
is which is fantastic um we'll move on
from the mike pence thing um but there's
another video here but before we do that
i want to show you an article here
um i don't know if you said my two
favorite guys one of which was uh we had
bonehead of the week yeah charles
charles barnes was the one we had bone
in the week right and yeah these guys
both admitted to it yeah so so that
it appears that the judge is the
bonehead here because um i guess they
were uh they admitted to committing
voter fraud
where they you know
and i don't i don't know if they were
like uh doing bamboo ballots or
watermarking or i'm not really sure what
but actually i do know they double voted
for trump which right all the voter
fraud that has been found in the 2020
election like the actual evidence and
the pleas is trump is the republicans
committed
trying to steal the crazy crate i mean
like if somebody made a movie about just
the fraud stories i mean
right what's funny is both these guys
are from the villages like the city
right now isn't there four people
charging there are four there are four
people that i know of i don't think
there was a fifth one but there's four
people which means that the villages
has the highest concentration of voter
fraud in the us
in the u.s that's funny where did the
voter fraud happen the most were there
most people in the same area in the same
region
the villages which is called the
friendliest neighborhood in america
is it on the sign that's on the side
yeah i did a tweet uh uh if you go
uh to my profile
oh so now i have now i have to go to you
you want me to give you the link i'll
give you the link yeah send the link
come on come on this executive producer
i'm telling you what i mean
but here's here's the thing here's the
thing that i want to say about this
story because we know these two [ __ ]
idiots are boneheads right like they
thought they were gonna get away with
voting twice which is really [ __ ]
dumb if you think you're gonna get away
with voting twice like there's an easy
way for them to track it and then charge
you for it but
that's why we don't really need all the
[ __ ] backstops for mail-in ballots
and all this [ __ ] that they're
talking about for integrity and
elections all they have to do is just do
their job but the judge
sentences these [ __ ] which i think the
maximum that the judge could have
sentenced him is like five years in a
florida prison
these he sends them to community service
and then they have to take a civics
class i'm not sure sounds about white to
me right there's that and i don't know
the story maybe you can find that
there's a story of a voter fraud of a
black woman in texas who uh was
convicted on voter fraud and it really
is kind of a bunch of [ __ ] because
she actually didn't know about her
registration and they could have just
thrown her ballot out it's not like she
maliciously did this and they actually
you know what they did to her gabe they
did her
are you aware what they did to the black
woman in texas
i feel like i i know where this is going
and i'm not gonna be happy about it they
did not give her community service right
that's not what they did um they
actually they uh put her in jail they
put her in prison they gave her a prison
so here's here's the here's that here's
the um um the tweet that you're looking
for here the villages is florida's
friendliest hometown
but something fraudulent is a foot
coming soon to a polling place near you
when a republican votes
uh
welcome to the villages florida's finest
friendlies
and that's the actual sign that's the
actual sign there's nothing this is an
actual photo from the villages all i did
was i added a sepia tone and i had a
text on it that was oh okay you made it
real dramatic then yeah and then and
then these four names up here are the
four people these are the four people
yeah yeah in the villages that are so
barnes and ketchik are the two that were
uh that that uh
admitted to voting twice right the
recent ones now rather the other two
will or not or whether they were
convicted i'm not really sure maybe
maybe they'll try to i mean maybe they
all met up on the same night to be like
okay
like bridge club or whatever the [ __ ]
they're doing you know they're like oh
let's go vote because there's probably a
polling place maybe inside the villages
because they're like listen we don't
want people traveling very far get in
your golf cart drive from the cafeteria
area the dining hall to your residence
community the community the community
hall right like get your food and then
go and vote right and uh uh you know
they're like listen this is the plan
okay this is the plan we're gonna go
before we eat dinner then we're gonna go
after we eat dinner and no one's gonna
even know
right also it's the fact that you could
you know like when i
go to vote here in la you know they go
and
i take my id i give it to them and then
they check through i have to confirm
something and then i sign
so i wonder like what the
if they're talking you know especially
trump and other republicans they're like
oh we need to show ids and we need to do
this and do this and do this
well then
if if these people were able to commit
voter fraud in a republican area
especially within florida
like what type of protocols or process
are in place for them like how are they
able to get away with this this is the
current system that your president was
was uh looking over right right well and
ron desantis
right exactly right so you're gonna tell
me through two levels if not more
through like a specific county level so
possibly three levels of republican
uh leadership you're gonna tell me that
voter fraud happened under your
different watches right sorry bro that
sounds like a you problem not a me
problem right right i think i think we
should definitely uh um
investigate machines somewhere in the
villages i don't know if it's like
there's probably still there's probably
still fax machines oh here's the thing i
bet you those machines are so old if not
they're using paper ballots right and
they're using the like you have to punch
it through yourself and they're probably
in some like storage closet down in the
basement where they have all the stuff
for bingo you know right well it happens
maybe that's what they need to seize as
the bingo machines down at the villages
speaking
mike lindell said he said he wanted all
the machines right speaking speaking of
machine like things uh we have ben
shapiro here um with this uh
with this video
this is this is let's see this is only
11 this is only 11 seconds look it's
but let's let's give the audience a
little background on this because it is
very important that the audience knows
why this person in the audience um
does the thing that they do and says the
thing they need to say because ben
shapiro weirdly has on his show um has
said some
some really
things that really weren't like
instigated about his wife and her vagina
right like we are we are almost
two years in to this initial moment
happening right okay when he made the
comments i mean when he made the comment
about his wife
like right so the song comes out you
know whap what ass [ __ ] right right
right you're talking about the cardi b
song where are you so there's some boars
in this house yeah [ __ ] in this house
there's some [ __ ] in this house is
that the song yeah yeah yeah i did my
own version that was about uh cicadas oh
okay you know
but uh she releases that song in the
summer of 2020 so it's like you know
we're going through the pandemic yeah
there's only you know [ __ ] in this
house because we're locked in the house
right exactly you know and everyone
loves that
i
mean
it defends really fragile white men
right but most people like the song [ __ ]
which stands for wet ass [ __ ] yeah it's
a it's a banger yeah right you know it's
fun it really pisses you know what
pisses them off the music video that's
what really oh yeah because they're
going to go over and watch it like oh
there must it must be really sexy
because it talks about wet ass [ __ ] and
these fragile white men go over
and it's a bunch of you know half naked
and they just freak out probably yeah
they just freaked out there's nothing
wet or [ __ ] right oh my god right right
they just confuse this that's probably
why they're mad about it yeah so she
releases that song the internet goes
whoa this is crazy this is cool we like
the song blah blah blah
ben shapiro just throws himself into the
conversation republicans have a tendency
to drag themselves
through the mud
willingly
they are like they just throw themselves
into like the topic and everyone's like
nobody ever called for your opinion but
now that you're here okay that's an
awful take and you just like almost
incriminated yourself and revealed
something about your own personal life
that now people are just gonna make more
fun of and now it's two years later and
that [ __ ] is not getting old anytime
soon and it lives in this 11 seconds oh
just
i mean it is just just sweet sweet i
don't know who is first time but they
deserve a medal oh you know they're the
hero of 2022 well you should see the
look on the face
of this person when they say this
because they know they know like
oh this is it baby this is all i got
this if someone's got this and so
confident they don't hesitate they know
exactly what they're gonna say their
dismount is great the landing is great
um even the person holding the
microphone it takes them several seconds
to even know what the hell is going on
and even the crowd is like
right so tell us about tell us about
what ben shapiro in kind of a nutshell
ben shapiro said about his wife's vagina
when he was commenting on the womp song
because he was saying basically that he
did [ __ ] aren't wet is that what he
was saying i mean yeah
you know he is
you can say it gabe i'm trying to get on
his show that [ __ ] are dry right and
his and he doesn't get his wife wet
right and his that that is not a thing
that happens yeah that's the a thing
that happened his wife is a doctor and
was like totally normal totally normal
you know
totally i i don't get wet you know right
so she told him this yeah yeah and
benjamin i don't know if he really
processed what she said
and maybe she was like hint wink wink
like uh maybe the song brought this up
like at their house like he's like you
know beck
i've heard this song wet ass [ __ ] [ __ ]
and back a while ago you were stating
something and that like this is what
brought this this you know old thing up
in in their in their conversation right
while they were pro who knows they were
probably just eating cans of peas
doesn't seem like like that's what their
dinner would be is ben shapiro he just
he doesn't eat meals he's just like
eating peas or you know so
so that's where well that's where the
the the dap came from which is dry ass
[ __ ] and people
were now but i think his original tweet
if i look it up it says also i discussed
on the show my only real concern is that
the women involved who apparently
require a bucket and a mop get a medical
care they require
my doctor's wife differential diagnosis
bacterial vaginosis yeast infection and
trichomonas
trichomonasis so
it's uh he literally does not understand
art he does not understand right cardi b
in that song is saying bucket and a mop
like
like to describe to describe what is
happening in the song like the narrative
god forbid a woman is like oh my god i'm
really turned on and aroused by this
other person right right you know
whatever god forbid and and but god
forbid a woman loves sex i mean a man
sex all day long right right but if a
woman does it they're a truck or [ __ ]
whatever it is like derogatory way so
like god forbid it's like this person's
like oh my god i'm so turned on [ __ ]
open the floodgates this person just
like wrecked me right now and then ben
shapiro is like
uh
you need a bucket and a mop
my wife uh is
is the opposite right uh you know it's
like
it's you know without going into detail
about bench barrel's
dry ass [ __ ] situation right uh you
know
his
dab right yeah but i look at that and
i'm like oh you you brought yourself
into you decided to commentate on this
song and what was happening culturally
and then you said uh
actually this seems like a real big
issue on just like a in an infection or
some sort of a diagnosis my wife she
says that's not really a thing you know
right well you know i think what he's
saying here is women getting horny or
you know as you say
what did you say
real or i don't know what you're correct
getting correct getting wrecked yeah
which is great a woman getting wrecked
and a woman aroused
he's saying it's a medical condition
yeah they're saying like god forbid this
person is really aroused and is showing
that they're wet and he goes uh actually
my wife said uh that it's a medical
condition and she probably has some sort
of infection a yeast infection or
bacterial and everyone's like you bench
appear way too good you're way too good
and everyone's like ben why did you even
why did why did you even come in the
conversation like clearly someone's not
coming here and it's not going to be you
you know
well my advice to you gabe is to keep
that voice down because that voice may
just dap
in your house you if you if you do the
bench bureau way too much
you may actually
my wife has a dry ass [ __ ] uh
happy i'm so happy that vince appeared
that this happened because now we can
have this conversation right you know
without without ben shapiro doing this
stupid thing we can't have these
conversations yeah it's honestly
hilarious because again republicans
willingly drag themselves through the
[ __ ] right because they try to make some
point or like mansplain or just just
sort of like well my opinion my opinion
matters and then what ends up happening
is everyone goes no you're just thomas
[ __ ] and you could not just read what
the song was talking about you took it
literally and took it as a bad thing
right when it is a good thing right and
it's art too she's trying to make a
description but i guess those have never
experienced it don't understand it right
right
the best part here about this video is
here we are two years later because
really ben shapiro probably in his own
mind is like wow we're way past the
whole dap thing we're way past that and
we are not past that and i don't think
we'll ever be passionate we'll never be
past it it's now he's speaking at some
kind of uh lecture series or something
and the fred and linda allen yeah i'm
not sure what the hell that is i'm not
sure what the hell that is
but it sounds like you're looking it up
so so i'll let you look that up and and
give us context um of of the speech that
he's giving but let's watch the video
here because it is a beautiful 11
seconds everyone uh keep your ears open
here
uh not for ben shapiro but the person
who speaks after him who is in the
audience who is speaking into a
microphone dysphoria which is that i use
throughout the speech not gender you
sound like a bozo and you get no [ __ ]
and you can't even make your wife wet
bro so what's good
[Laughter]
like what's good and i was like
[Music]
so the first part the first part because
ben shapiro obviously is going at this
person
which is which is a standard thing that
ben shapiro does he'll go to these talks
give these lectures someone will say hey
you have this point of view however it's
incorrect because of this and then
benchmark goes actually uh based on
research and then it's like well that
research wasn't real and ben shapiro is
notorious he does it on uh joe rogan's
when he goes on that show he's notorious
for either
uh fabricating stats or he will
exaggerate them to prove his point so
every time he talks he's like well
actually there is a study done on family
learning and all this other [ __ ] like
you can literally just make fart sounds
and yeah yeah just as just as helpful
well one of the best videos other than
this one now one of the i mean this has
got to be the best bench bureau video
that's out there
now now the second best venture bureau
is when he's describing uh ocean levels
rising he's like oh well the people in
florida can just sell their property
like ben if the [ __ ] house is
underwater
no one like he clearly does not
understand like supply and demand like
this guy's video he's some kind of smart
[ __ ]
and he clearly does not understand it
let's play while you're looking for that
let's play this one more time because
like we gotta see this one more time i
use throughout the speech not generally
you sound like a bozo bro
you get no [ __ ] and you can't even make
your wife wet bro so what's good
and the entire crowd because
most of the crowd is there because they
love
shapiro like why would you go to like
you know i i've been saying the last
week uh our last three weeks every time
there's a trump rally like i'd rather
eat a big bag of dog [ __ ] then go to a
trump rally but maybe there is cause if
someone would pass around a microphone
and give someone the the time to speak
at a trump rally maybe there is cause to
go to trump rally like this beautiful
person did at whatever kind of lecture
series this year yeah so oh yeah so let
me give you context quickly when i
looked it up it's uh it's part of the
shapiro lecture tour it's young
america's foundation
the fred and linda allen lecture series
uh
uh he's
fred allen is the owner and founder of
geosoils a
uh geotechnical consulting company in
southern california so it just looks
like uh they hosted him but it was part
of this
um
right-wing fascists trying to play
right like they're part of normal
society amanda says um ben shapiro's
voice could dry up entire rivers
uh dapp um would make a great parody
song d says from facebook
i'm sure here's the thing i'm sure
somebody already made that song angela
from facebook wants us to play it again
so i'll play it one more time all right
i've got the other video right now okay
okay go ahead and send me that link and
we'll we'll play this one one more time
the number one ben shapiro video out
there on the internet right now
until someone tops this one which i
don't know if you will here it is one
more time throughout the speech not
generally you sound like a bozo and you
get no [ __ ] and you can't even make
your wife
you can't help but laugh every single
time it's fantastic he's like bro bro
bro you're a boso
you can't even make your wife white bro
bro bro oh my god it's it's
fantastic what's this one that you're
going to show this is the one where he's
talking about the this is the one where
he's talking about the uh
the water levels the water levels around
the world rise by by let's say five feet
over the next hundred years say ten feet
by the next hundred years and it puts
all the low-lying areas on the coast
underwater right which let's say all of
that happens you think that people
aren't going to just sell their homes
and move
[Laughter]
oh my god sell it to aquaman that's
that's fantastic that's right
so speaking speaking of more boneheads
and more you you brought up um uh joe
rogan and ben shapiro being on saying
really stupid [ __ ] on joe rogan yeah
where there was someone else there was
someone else on joe rogan which has been
saying really stupid things and someone
told joe logan
uh well
every single time but uh bill maher um
oh yeah i didn't watch the clip i saw he
was on there yeah yeah we're gonna watch
it here real quick but to give you guys
context then someone pointed this out
that bill maher has really figured out
that hey liberals hating him really gets
him trending and gets him ratings uh so
that's what he's doing so we're gonna
give him more ratings here we're going
to give him more attention because we
can't how dare you
oh damn
it's a great it's actually a great clip
and the reason why it's a great clip is
because they're talking about how the
vaccine is a cure which is really
[ __ ] dumb but they're like oh you
can't trust you can't trust the cdc in
science because they don't know anything
about medical decisions and then they're
smoking these big huge fat cigars like
oh yeah okay yeah i'm gonna take medical
advice from you then but let's let's
watch a little bit of this video here uh
of of uh
the the brilliant joe rogan and the even
greater mind of science and uh medical
advice these are the two most brilliant
men right right in every world right and
a lot of people are upset that bill
maher is um
is is going right which bill maher was
never really a lefty i mean he is in
some respects but bill maher has a lot
of libertarian type
you know he has this hint of libertarian
even when he had a show before uh his
hbo show real time with bill maher he
had politically incorrect and he's
really he was really anti-government
even back then yeah um you know which is
really libertarian so his trust or his
mistrust i should say of the government
and the cdc here is really not
surprising so anyone who gets like also
willing to just throw the n word around
as well no big deal wow
they have that in common right exactly
so let's watch the video here of these
boneheads
no i mean i probably have but it's like
i don't know
i would trust it it came from the cdc if
they if they personally admitted yes
this is or the people who make the
vaccine
anybody else i don't know but that did
you see the huff of smoke oh yeah that's
the big story
right this is this is joe rogan's
smoking here so so uh dr bill lamarr
here is giving his take on medical
advice while joe rogan huffs on a bigger
let me just join the crew here yeah all
right there you go there you go there's
the
[Laughter]
then again they could be lying i also
don't tell them don't trust them to tell
me the truth this whole this this whole
uh well they're probably telling the
truth but they may be lying so you can't
trust them because maybe they're lying
maybe they're telling the truth this is
really [ __ ] stupid [ __ ] yeah but
listen listen to the next lead up here
about the vaccine because i think that's
important about whether they did put it
in there and i don't know what the
[ __ ] [ __ ] is that
maybe maybe it's the stuff in twinkies
and maybe it's the rocket fuel that you
take to look like that in your age i
don't know what the [ __ ] it is or
literally listed on the website right
tell you the ingredients right the other
thing the other thing crazy here is bill
maher is saying the rocket fuel that you
makes you look like you look like the
[ __ ] that the indiscriminate [ __ ] that
you stick in your body yeah you have no
idea what it is or how it will affect
you joe rogan to look as young as you
look or whatever the [ __ ] he's trying to
say like oh well that's okay so it's
just [ __ ] ridiculous but listen to
this part about the vaccine being a cure
if it's going to be bad for me here's
here's my thing about
my overarching theme always about
anything medical is
everyone else i feel or most people
are giving us too much credit
for where we are medically because we
are of course
further along than we used to be you
know we're not putting wooden teeth into
people right so that's the bar wooden
teeth in people is the bark get the [ __ ]
out here listen
we're gonna continue here you know i
mean it wasn't that long ago they were
rubbing dirt into woods i mean just some
really stupid [ __ ] things that people
did
who were killing themselves so obviously
right i know like well in the dirt and
people's wounds what the [ __ ] is he
talking about i mean he's talking about
like mud band-aids or some [ __ ] or i
mean i don't know exactly what he's
talking about but he's he's he's really
acting as if we do not have the ability
to know medical things and listen to
what he says here about cancer this is
super important what he says about this
come a long way just in the last hundred
years
but but my
point of view is that we are still at
the infancy you were so understanding
what the [ __ ] are you how the human body
works so don't tell me things like just
do it literally
they are growing
[ __ ] hearts they are growing hearts
they are they can grow actual human body
parts now they're they're not exactly to
the point to where they can confidently
use a lot of these things right but
we what the [ __ ] are you talking about
we're in an embassy we can make human
body parts out of cells you are a dumb
[ __ ] if you think that we are in
the emphasis of medic
and not only that of biology
science about viruses
right it is absolutely ridiculous that
we don't know about viruses but listen
to [ __ ] about cancer what we say don't
question it
when have we ever been wrong
a lot all the time i've been wrong a lot
and you just don't know a lot
you haven't cured cancer i'm not blaming
you for that i know you're trying
but and i could name a thousand other
things you haven't cured of parkinson's
and ms and
lyme disease you just don't know very
much
it is absolutely ridiculous because it
feels like to me what these two
boneheads are saying is that because the
vaccine isn't a cure which they i don't
know why they [ __ ] think batman said
it was a cure right
no one no one no no
if we can you know uh treat people with
the vaccine then we lower the the
frequency and likelihood that this
disease or virus replicates to a point
where it is basically eradicated it's
not a cure it's a treatment to remove
anything it's like why because you can't
cure a virus there's no right here for a
virus that's not like there's no cure
for the flu you dumb [ __ ] just
like there's no cure for the gqp you
know it's right exactly it's a [ __ ]
disease it's a virus and you can't get
rid of it it's always gonna be there i
mean it just how much can you like do a
vaccine so that way it doesn't spread
around and infect people like the you
know the petticon republican kid
diddling gqp right you're saying so i
don't know this is [ __ ] ridiculous
and really honestly um no one should be
surprised that bill maher and joe rogan
are even are saying dumb [ __ ] like this
into a microphone it is not it is really
not that surprising there's one more
video that i want to um
oh oh yes um
speaking of the
kid diddling gqp and the
the republican pedocons we have ron
desantis in florida the fascist ron
desantis
in florida um oh my god this is this is
a real disturbing video i'm just you
know what i'm just gonna play it and we
can commentate as it goes here i'm gonna
turn it down a bit um but as you can see
we're at a press conference here and if
you look
at the paused image here
up front is where ron desantis is going
to be speaking
um and where these looks like um this
guy here and this guy here looks like
security detail yeah sunglasses on the
inside can't see my eyes baby for
governor hitler um i mean desantis um
they're going to um they're going to
come back here to the media pool which
if you see this lady here she's looking
at the media pool and the person with
the camera is standing in the media pool
so let's watch what happens
you can see they're they're showing the
media here all the media is there for
the event
um media is invited to events like this
and this person right here is is being
asked to leave now you see the security
detail and you also see a police officer
here and some police officers in the
background here
i'm gonna remove this person from the
press pool who is has press
conventionals watch this
i sent an email actually
we have a screening process you just
needed are you guys afraid of tough
questions i just wanted to ask the
governor governor about the 624 million
dollar tax refund for wealthy
corporations
including the 10 million that disney's
gonna get from our tax dollars you guys
should ask about that
so here we have a reporter asking a
question and he shouts out the question
now here's the great part about our
democracy here's the great part about
the internet because everyone's like oh
you know this this [ __ ] never happened
before the internet listen without the
internet we would not have known about
this yeah yeah not a known about this
you have not known that they would have
suppressed that they removed people from
the press pool because ron desantis
doesn't want to doesn't want not even
answer their questions doesn't even want
them asking the questions out loud for a
group that really pushes the first
amendment their first amendment first
amendment we gotta we gotta have the
first amendment protected you're over
here telling that there actually isn't
the freedom of the press you're telling
me that they're actually going to remove
that
now gabe this is anti-cancer people who
are trying to cancel disney because
disney says don't do that bigoted ass
[ __ ] that don't say gay bill
and then this person is asking this
reporter is asking about disney's
actual [ __ ] financial stake in the
don't say gay bill because that's the
truth the truth is is that this this
idea that disney is somehow woke right
which i mean i guess the idea that the
ceo of disney realized how bad this bill
was and how discriminatory this bill was
and that his employees were not okay
with it after they threatened to walk
out at disney world he changed his mind
and that's how [ __ ] works that's how
democracy actually works if you want to
know people change their [ __ ] minds
and rather
disney's ceo morally changed his mind or
thought you know what this is going to
be bad for business who gives a [ __ ] who
gives a [ __ ] but this reporter is
actually trying to ask a question about
that right and and the thing that the
thing that is crazy here is this person
who is holding the camera filming this
watch what happens
stay tuned here of what happens when
they remove this reporter and they come
back for the person who's taking the
video
corporations are going to get a 624
million dollar corporate tax refund from
this legislature
and this mean is going to get 10 million
dollars
why are you guys assaulting a person
this is a credential press person who
rsvp'd for this event
they were moved because they knew they'd
be tough now watch what happens to the
person who has the camera oh did it
maybe i have the i don't have the full
video okay so the person the person who
has the the camera because that's grant
stern in there right
um isn't grant stern right there holding
the k like not holding the camera that's
filming but wasn't he in the in the room
there yes grant stern is right right
right there yep beer this is grant stern
right here holding a camera this yeah
because he here's the thing grant stern
has already experienced this exact thing
he was pulled out of a press conference
with ron desantis
and actually i think sustained an injury
when the cops literally just like
harassed him and assaulted him on the
way out
right um but they also removed the
person who is taking this video or is it
grant that they remove i think it's this
person that they removed i don't have
the full video here um this is not the
full video but they remove this person
as well and when they go outside of
course they're you know talking about
the freedom of press and all this kind
of stuff so if you're if you're out
there wondering what the republican
pedocon kid diddling gqp is going to do
and how they want to do it they want to
do it fascist style where you cannot
even ask a question that they don't want
to hear not even you don't ha because
ron desantis doesn't have to answer any
question yeah he can ignore it he is
free to tell them to go [ __ ] themselves
right i mean he literally can look at
the breasts and say go [ __ ] yourself
right and there would be i mean other
than election consequences there would
be no consequences because it's a
freedom of speech thing he gets to say
go [ __ ] yourself i mean we've seen chris
christie actually say i think in so many
years yeah it looks like uh
yeah kathleen confirmed that they did
remove that's what i thought i thought
grant was yeah as well so which means
that's the second time i know that he
also had a lawsuit against desantis
uh for for putting him on a list that
was like a no press list even though he
didn't do anything illegal the other
thing here is that you know you've got
you've got a group of people who again
are using the first amendment so when
you've got these gqp
pedo con kitty did alert you know
whatever
um
you say oh hey well if we like the
freedom of the press right you like the
free speech like the first amendment
like yeah yeah okay well then explain
how this person who is part of the press
and asking a question why they're
getting kicked out right because if this
was anywhere reversed like if it was a
democrat or it was a republican uh
asking joe biden a question and they
were getting assaulted and and dragged
out outside
the
these people would oh god they were
going nuts uh first amendment
[Music]
right exactly speaking of so so yeah i
just look at that scenario and i'm like
how do you explain
you know the back and forth and you
can't because it's just hip-hop it's
just hypocrisy from the group right well
i mean obviously obviously um those
those cops uh violated
those press uh hipaa hipaa it violated
their hipaa really honestly and i'm sure
that i'm sure desantis is you know using
his marjorie taylor green gazpacho
police right probably probably ask for
the papers and prove who they are i'm
sure i'm sure that's right uh speaking
of q anon and crazy here um and and
just speaking of gitmo um this is a
video from the good liars from uh the
trump rally it is absolutely [ __ ]
bonkers i said it's a q anon world out
there we're just living in it folks i've
been saying this for a couple days the
good liars had a video we talked to a
woman who thinks dr fauci is currently
being held in guantanamo bay
this is really [ __ ] spooky [ __ ] um
and and the reason why is because like
this could be your your aunt nancy right
yeah um i hey she looks like a nancy i
don't know her actual name um but let's
listen to what she says not just about
fouchy but about the obamas and the
clintons let's listen what do you think
about anthony fauci
oh my god i can't even believe he made
it this far
what what
he made it this far like i what i i'm
not sure exactly what that means i don't
know i don't know if it means like this
far in life or he got that position or
she's surprised he's not dead for some
reason i'm gonna here's the thing i'm
gonna just because i'm a realist right
i'm gonna say that the reaction that she
had was based on a life death situation
and made it this far is because he's
alive because i'm sure this was like
also like i sent him [ __ ] white
powder in the mail and thought i don't
know and i made death right right she's
part of that i guarantee she's part of
that same group of people
who were sending death threats and
sending um
different things that you know could
could make someone afraid for the
position they held because they didn't
like the fact that he was just doing his
job right and trump made it political
trump was the one who made his who made
fouchy you know famous
and that's the reason why they all hate
him well i mean when you go to a nazi
rally you end up running into some nazis
like this lady
listen to the crazy because the the
thing which she says where i don't i
can't believe you made it that far like
you can interpret that 100 different
ways right like i'm interpreting only
one way right well right but i mean a
person could reasonably say well that's
not so crazy if you put it in certain
contexts but listen to what she follows
it up with uh no i just the guy's gone
the guy's he's in gitmo he's in gitmo
so
really uh he
[ __ ] confused here he's really like
what
is going on
right so for the um for anyone out there
who doesn't which i don't understand how
you cannot know what gitmo is or
guantanamo bay or the prison that
guantanamo will be yeah for those who
don't know guantanamo bay and the gitmo
is a
well it's a military base but there is a
prison there where they hold terrorists
and they hold them there because it's
kind of like a limbo thing you know like
and you know it's kind of like purgatory
for
terrorists uh for us to detain them
forever but listen to what she says
after she says anthony fauci is in gitmo
like she believes that dr anthony mauchi
is in gitmo let's listen really who else
is in gitmo besides anthony fauci you
know you got hollywood there you've got
politicians you've got elites the
clintons are there the obamas are there
you know um it goes on and on i don't
want to be the one to sit here and and
misquote somebody or say something but
they didn't
irresponsible
you don't want to say anything you're
responsible
so the the thing is here about the about
who she thinks is in gitmo so when you
when you break this down and i watched i
watched this at least 15 times trying to
figure out what the [ __ ] she was talking
about because it is so [ __ ] batshit
crazy she's they're all doubles right i
bet she's she's in frame i i don't know
because i don't i actually believe i
think the question to ask this woman and
i wish we could find her and bring her
on the show and actually answer this
question because the question is that's
great you can't find her she's not like
that's true i would but she's probably
in some facebook ivermectin group
somewhere she's got a tinfoil hat right
right right but if i had a question ask
her i would ask her this
what is gitmo because it feels like she
thinks it's like some kind of liberal
island somewhere where people are
partying like club fed but because she's
like hollywood is there like what and
then the obamas and the clintons maybe
she's referring to uh i don't know i
think what she's referring to is one
from the gate she goes i'm surprised he
made this part which is like i'm
surprised he's still alive
um
then in addition to that i think when
she says like
uh hollywood elites this and that like i
think she's
she's referring to the cabal she's like
all these people are all people that
have been referenced as the cabal right
these are all people who are part of
this baby blood sucking
uh sex orgy right something to be scared
of you got to be scared right right
right so i think whether she knows what
uh gitmo is you know also like i live in
hollywood like i'm not there am i a
double wait wait wait you this is you're
not recording from gitmo
i don't know
it's it's ridiculous speaking of cut the
air cut the feed right now
[Laughter]
speaking of i i want to show one more
video and we're we're 57 minutes into
the second hour so we're running out of
time here but there's one more video
that i want to show and the reason why
is because i want people to know the
truth out there uh speaking of absolute
[ __ ] bonkers ass [ __ ] where you would
create a second narrative
for people who don't know this is beto
o'rourke he's running for governor in
the state of texas but the current
governor greg abbott
greg abbott is actually
stopping all the trucks that come across
the border with goods and products all
the stuff that they want on those empty
biden shelves right yeah like all the
stuff that americans want he's stopping
all those trucks to inspect them to make
sure they're safely coming in this
country um with basically the texas
highway patrol yeah i mean it was pain
for the inspection right it's the text
it's the people of texas now uh the
thing that people don't know and which
people on fox news and like this q anon
uh aunt nancy that we just seen in the
good liars video probably think they're
inspecting the cargo but let's listen to
what better o'rourke says
in this in this video
welcome everybody i know that folks are
just beginning to tune in
and to roll onto the feed
but um
thank you for joining us i'm here in
laredo texas
on the u.s side of the u.s mexico border
and at one of the busiest
land ports in the united states of
america one of the busiest land ports in
the hemisphere this is the columbia
international
bridge right here in laredo texas and
behind me if you can see it are trucks
that are lined up as far as we can see
that have within them and you can see
here in the video like some of them are
actual bringing in uh vehicles like
right these here like that are
manufactured in mexico um obviously
there's big box trucks there's tanker
trucks um so there's a lot of goods and
services that are in this line um that
are going to come across the border that
are manufactured in mexico with the deal
which which which is crazy because
remember there was a guy a president um
i forget it was the last guy who talked
about redoing the trade deal in mexico
and that's right you know yeah yeah
yeah right yeah yeah okay so so that is
what this is so let's listen into more
what better says the things that we want
in this country um the cars the
televisions um the food the produce the
the things that we expect to see in our
stores in on the shelves of our super
those empty biden shelves things right
upon
to make sure that we can live our lives
and this backup that you see that's been
going on now for almost a week
is not just a function of being on the
border um it has a lot to do in fact it
has everything to do with the governor
of the state of texas greg abbott who
has mandated a an ex an inspection for
each one of these trucks coming north
and listen to what he says about the
inspections
so it's the higher patrol supposedly
increased security at the border but all
those troopers can do is look at the
tire pressure um they can look at how
the the engine of that truck is running
they can perform a safety inspection on
the vehicle itself but they're unable to
actually look at the cargo oh for [ __ ]
sake so they're basically doing a safety
inspection on the highway where it's
like a traffic stop and and this is this
is what they're trying to do greg abbott
is trying to clog up the border so that
goods uh like he was saying fruits
vegetables food vehicles stuff that goes
on your shelf that is that is you that
is yelling and screaming about inflation
and empty shelves greg abbott is using
texas
tax dollars the people in texas tax
dollars to try to create this narrative
that not only not only we're securing
the border by stopping a bunch of
mexicans from coming across it because
that's the narrative but they're also
they're also contributing to the empty
shelves that because remember trump he
went into tiffany's a couple weeks ago
and there was no bread so i'm sure i'm
sure i'm sorry he went into tiffany's
and there was no bread come on man
that's the narrative that we're playing
here yeah oh
god oh okay i didn't know you i thought
when he went into tiffany's he saw rudy
giuliani dressed up in dragon well that
that is that is true but he was trying
to find the bread aisle in tiffany's you
know there just isn't any bread on the
shelves right right no bread yeah no
bread no bread especially especially
none of that mexican bread because greg
abbott is to making sure yeah yeah
that's just that mexican bread though
flat round bread
tortillas
it absolutely is insanity
and now abbott is his bussing people
he's bussing uh you know he says they're
illegal immigrants and he's busting them
into dc so that it's biden's problem
right like that's what he's doing now
which is
unbelievable so you know again it is
biden's problem because it is a federal
border and the feds are doing something
just like better roarick here is saying
the feds are controlling this border
they're coming across they're doing the
inspections that they have to do to make
sure that the cargo ships aren't
bringing through drugs and also humans
for human trafficking or just trying to
get people across the border like there
are people who are feds on the ground
doing that what the higher patrol doing
is stopping the line
stopping the line with tire pressure and
engine uh heat so will so that way that
way they don't move into the state and
they're actually spending not only
federal state dollars and federal
dollars to secure the border but gray
abbott if you're in texas he is spending
your tax money to create a narrative
that mexicans are coming across the
border and they're taking your jobs and
there's empty shells and they're trying
to con they're trying to manufacture
these crisis by manufacturing them
themselves if you ever needed a way uh
of how not to run a state county country
whatever uh please follow the path that
has been that has been set before you by
the gqp because they do a knockout job
right right well you know the other good
news right before we go because we're
gonna have to go here we're over time
here
the good news about texas is yesterday
in a poll if you believe polls
betto is just two points
behind greg abbott and i would bet i
would bet that's because greg abbott is
is using tax dollars to clog up and have
empty shelves
in texas so guys don't forget to follow
us on face on
facebook now we're on minus touch
facebook page go go uh follow us on
twitter at tony michaels pod tomorrow we
will have the bonehead of the week pull
up
uh there subscribe to the youtube
channel don't forget to just go to the
tony michaels podcast so you don't miss
anything you do not want to miss a
single minute after johnny michaels
podcast
live every single weekday monday through
friday noon eastern 11 central nine
pacific for all you hollywood gitmo
people out there yeah yeah i'm stuck in
gitmo baby right so turn your gitmo dial
if you're out there in hollywood at 9 00
a.m
noon eastern youtube twitter twitch and
now from the midas touch facebook page
until tomorrow surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries
i think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow tony
on social media at the tony michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after
me [ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking